[Música]
el expresidente de eeuu donald trump
busca ser nuevamente a la casa blanca
ahora desde la oposición al gobierno
demócrata de yo bailé y con una
estrategia centrada en más apariciones
públicas y mítines multitudinarios
un hecho de violencia enciende las
alarmas sobre la polarización social en
brasil mientras se acercan las
elecciones presidenciales los
simpatizantes de jair bolsonaro y de
luiz inácio lula da silva se enfrentaron
a tiros y en mexico la zona industrial
de monterrey ya enfrenta a una fuerte
sequía allí los habitantes deben
racionar el agua corriente y almacenarla
mientras que las empresas locales ya han
tenido que reducir sus operaciones
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
informativa de france 24 en español
dedicada a las principales noticias del
continente americano y comenzamos en
eeuu y es que el ex presidente de donald
trump busca llegar nuevamente a la casa
blanca y ahora lo hace desde la
oposición al gobierno demócrata de yo
vaivén aunque es criticar las decisiones
del mandatario no es su única estrategia
rafael pérez nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe
unas apariciones en público y mítines
multitudinarios esa al parecer es la
nueva estrategia del ex presidente de
donald trump ahora como me escena de los
miembros del partido republicano que
optan por cargos públicos en su futuro
depende de los republicanos
conquistando el control del congreso si
esto pasa trump triunfa así que si en su
interés de apoyar a los candidatos
republicanos a donde encuentran
dificultades desde la oposición trump
fustiga las decisiones de joe biden
creando un estado de opinión que lo
ayuda a llegar al salón oval
somos una nación que se rindió en
afganistán dejando atrás soldados y
ciudadanos estadounidenses muertos y 85
mil millones de dólares en el mejor
equipo militar del mundo somos una
nación que permitió que rusia devastar a
un país ucrania matando a cientos de
miles de personas y sólo empeorará
edwards sin embargo a pesar de la
investigación por el asalto al capitolio
y sus constantes críticas al sistema
electoral puede trump llegar nuevamente
a la casa blanca
expertos creen que la actual crisis
mundial y sus efectos le allana el
camino con la inflación en eeuu el
precio de la gasolina subiendo los
precios en los supermercados muy muy
fuertes en salida etcétera etcétera
baile no está navegando muy bien eso es
suficiente
para trump decir ustedes necesitan que
yo regrese a la casa blanca del tiempo
es un factor clave para la actual
administración de cara a las elecciones
de medio término éstas le permitirán a
bailén continuar con su programa o
fortalecer la figura de su contrincante
y hechos de violencia contra migrantes
en la frontera sur de eeuu con un de
relieve la problemática que representa
el tráfico de personas en medio de la
crisis migratoria que se vive en esta
región y uno de los últimos episodios
hablamos de la muerte de 53 migrantes en
un trailer en texas refleja el
incremento de este tipo de delitos y
también del uso de coyotes en la
frontera con mexico en france 24
dialogamos con jorge andrade experto en
temas migratorios sobre como algunas
normativas como el título 42 usada para
hacer retornar a personas por motivos
sanitarios agudizaron este flagelo
totalmente en la pandemia agudizó es ese
punto que te señala es muy bien y
también pues bueno vemos las economías
de los países de donde surgen de dónde
vienen estas personas los países de
origen que tienen situaciones económicas
agravadas por la pandemia y que están
tratando de llegar a eeuu y un claro
ejemplo es el título 42 y el cierre de
fronteras en el norte del país como en
el sur
y en brasil un hecho de violencia
enciende las alarmas sobre la
polarización social que atraviesa la
nación sudamericana mientras se acercan
las elecciones presidenciales de octubre
los hechos ocurrieron la pasada
madrugada en foz do iguazú cuando buen
agente penitenciario seguidor del
presidente de jair bolsonaro irrumpió en
la fiesta de cumpleaños de un integrante
del partido de los trabajadores y abrió
fuego contra éste provocándole la muerte
en la gente también recibió disparos y
se encuentra internado en grave estado
el hecho es para muchos reflejo del
clima de polarización social que
atraviesa el país a menos de tres meses
de las elecciones presidenciales aunque
para otros como el consultor político
cayó maya en el y brasil no es escenario
de una grieta social
no necesariamente
no podríamos llamar de una politización
social en la dimensión del país la gente
de hecho es alejada de la política no
estamos hablando de un país como
paraguay por ejemplo que tiene 50 por
ciento de su población afiliar a un
partido tenemos y sé que tenemos
más de 20 partidos en brasil y
posiblemente si tenemos una población
20% de la población afiliada a todos
estos partidos es mucho entonces lo que
se mira es una escalada de violencia
incitada por el propio señor jair
bolsonaro
por el propio presidente de la república
que desde que empecé el gobierno empieza
a hacer discursos de odio o discursos de
discriminatorios discursos enseñando o
enseñando una frustración y incentivando
a la gente a responder de manera
violenta sus frustraciones en relación
al partido trabajadores y en méjico de
la zona industrial de monterrey está
enfrentando una fuerte sequía que causa
estragos en la vida de sus habitantes
con solo unas horas de agua corriente al
día la gente intenta almacenar litros en
sus hogares y las empresas locales ya
tuvieron que reducir sus operaciones
alva santana tiene los detalles
es una de las zonas más ricas de méxico
monterrey nuevo léon goza de un nivel de
vida con el que muchas zonas del país no
podrían ni soñar pero en los últimos
meses una ola de calor y la falta de
lluvias ha provocado la escasez de algo
esencial el agua en la pandemia penas
como que nos estábamos dando un respiro
verdadero apenas nos estamos dando un
respiro yo creo como un respiro muy
corto casi nada y empezó la seguir con
sólo unas horas de agua corriente al día
desde hace casi dos meses a muchos como
a maría navarro les toca ir a llenar
cubos de agua de los camiones cisterna y
llevarlos a sus casas ya que casi nadie
puede permitirse comprar tanques para
almacenar el líquido
y una vez más
la calle tiene que venir la agua pero me
desespero mucho con ante el clima árido
y las temperaturas de hasta 38 grados
celsius en la zona en verano complica en
el flujo de agua al igual que las muchas
empresas de la zona que consumen
cantidades enormes del preciado líquido
en esta parte hay que recordar lo que lo
que está determinado en la ley de aguas
nacionales donde en épocas de crisis e
incertidumbre siempre hay una prioridad
en el consumo humano sobre las
explotaciones industriales y agrícolas
sin embargo eso no está ocurriendo de
manera suficiente motivo por el que tras
negociaciones con las autoridades
locales las fábricas de la zona han
dejado de operar unos días a la semana
para ahorrar agua dejando un escenario
desierto en las afueras de la localidad
seguimos en mexico la iglesia santo
domingo en san cristóbal de las casas en
chiapas fue devuelta renovada a sus
fieles después de haber sido destruida
en el año 2017 por el sismo que sacudió
al país veamos el informe que nos cuenta
la historia del exconvento pero también
de su reparación
el ex convento de santo domingo una joya
del sureste mexicano construida en el
siglo 16 a renació de los escombros tras
su restauración después del sismo que
azotó a méxico hace cinco años después
de un lustro dedicado a trabajos de
reparación el templo fue entregado este
sábado por el presidente mismo a los
fieles católicos en la ciudad colonial
de san cristóbal de las casas
pilar garcía quintana miembro del
consejo consultivo del centro histórico
de san cristóbal explica la importancia
de esta renovación para la ciudad muy
difícil ha sido muy difícil pero hemos
estado con mucho entusiasmo queremos
recuperar las cosas preciosas que tiene
san cristóbal los monumentos que son
patrimonio en la ciudad la iglesia fue
una de las primeras sedes religiosas
establecidas por los misioneros en
méxico está considerada como la obra
cumbre del barroco centroamericano y
mezcla elementos coloniales e indígenas
obra como digo pues del pueblo
los pueblos originarios
con este rol
y
[Música]
el apoyo también de la corona
debido a los daños ocasionados por el
sismo de magnitud 82 grados registrado
el 7 de septiembre de 2017
el templo santo domingo- fue uno de los
22 inmuebles históricos
intervenidos por el instituto nacional
de antropología e historia para su
reparación en esta ciudad
es todo por el momento regresamos en
breve con muchas más noticias sigan en
france 24
[Música]